think about this confluence of different
technologies suddenly becoming a big
enabler of a revolutionary new step
self-driving vehicles were enabled by
advances in sensing capability
electronics becoming smaller faster and
cheaper and then when you combine that
with artificial intelligence improvement
that we have seen over the past decade
or so that in turn is enabling the
creation and deployment of sampling
vehicles if we are able to sense all
activities happening within a
metropolitan region things happening in
transportation water sewage air quality
noise quality law enforcement healthcare
you name it if you can basically sense
those things process that with the
enormous amounts of computational power
that we have at our disposal today and
then run a on it we can actually extract
inferences trends and patterns which can
be exploited fed back to citizens
planners decision-makers employers and
long-term planners they can literally
make cities actually operate much more
efficiently and effectively making them
smarter and metropolitan lives like they
have a much better quality of life
there's not just about innovations in
technology that needs to be innovations
in policy as well so the the
improvements in policy and technology
really have to work with each other it's
not job-related technology's just doing
that in the air - division labs the
Dodgers about policy makers making
decisions in a vacuum mean to correctly
get this or two groups of people working
together talking to each other in the
same goal
welcome back from lunch I hope everybody
was able to get some food and it seemed
as though the conversation was perhaps
even better than the food which is
saying something it's wonderful to be
here to start the next session on policy
and governance that is how can we
perhaps not simply in a bottom-up
fashion as technology developers or as
people thinking about the as uses of
technology but perhaps in a more
top-down way think about the kinds of
structures and policies that we can put
into place to help ensure that these
technologies are actually serving our
human values our human interests our
human goals
how can nations work together how can
universities work together and so at
every level what kinds of governance
structures do we want and what can
advance our interests and our
technologies so we'll begin the session
as we did the last one with a talk by
one of our K&L gates presidential
fellows Allante Whitmore received her BS
and biological engineering from North
Carolina and T State University as well
as an MS in agricultural and biological
engineering from the University of
Illinois at urbana-champaign she's come
to us now here at CMU and as a PhD
student in both civil and environmental
engineering as well as engineering and
public policy so as you can see she's
sort of ideally situated for this
session and has been focusing her
research on the societal and the
environmental implications of this
transition that we're seeing in
Pittsburgh and globally to a more
automated more autonomous transportation
infrastructure so Allante thank you
the trolley problem is an on has
garnered a lot of attention with the
oncoming introduction of autonomous
vehicles take a minute with me and
imagine a trolley barreling down the
railway tracks and in front of it five
people that would be killed you can pull
a lever and on the other track there
there's another person that could be
killed on the one track we've replaced
the Charlie well our eyes are being
replaced with a sensor and the levers
replaced by a line of code and the
question has now become how will a vs
behave when at when an accident is
unavoidable we've become obsessed
fixated with this issue in academia
media private and public sector but I
kind of think that the trolley problem
is sort of limiting because it's
focusing on order their hardware and
software choices that we're making and
if we're ok with those decisions I want
to take a moment to kind of take a step
back and look at the avian ethics more
broadly in society and that's what I've
had the opportunity to do as a KL
presidential Kano gates presidential
fellow here at CMU the fatal uber crash
in Arizona a couple weeks ago is a
microcosm of these bigger ethical
questions questions beyond the Charlie
problem look at things like how do open
design come into play or lighting or
sight like silent sidewalk placement or
even what happens when a navy speeding
who's responsible the point is the
decisions that we make permeate outside
the confines which transportation and
mobility and we have to think about that
as planners policymakers and programmers
that will affect our society our access
and our access to opportunity
we can begin with our built environment
which we have to think about how are we
going to mix human and non-human drivers
that will be sharing the road for the
next couple of years previous
transportation revolutions have provided
a lot of opportunity and they've shaped
our cities they've also contributed to
pre-existing racial or socio-economic to
verities we have an opportunity now to
think more deeply about our work and the
outcomes and we can work to mitigate and
reduce those disparities from the
decisions made in the past we also can
be thinking about land exchange as a
these are posed to reduce parking demand
and so what are we going to do with that
land use just and how are we going to
allocate it so that the communities
where these new spaces available will be
impacted positively lastly we have to
think about policy and regulation as it
was largely shaped the outcomes of Av
deployment we know that one highly
contested point is how safe is safe
enough for AVS to be released to the
public we have to think about why are we
well one highly contested point of
course is like I said the idea of how
safe is safe enough one side argues we
need to have a these out immediately
because we are losing more lives in
fatal car crashes every day well on
other side argues it's unethical to
release a technology of this magnitude
without making sure that it's as safe as
we claim it to be now the things I've
covered are in no way comprehensive
rather a quick peek at what I'm along
with my research advisors are working on
I'm hoping that I can inform answers to
questions like what is societal and
environment so impacts of AVS or will
this potential shift to share mobility
hurt or help lower-income communities he
may have been thinking how can you apply
ethics into your work or if you even
should be concerned about it but the
reality is we should be very concerned
the Association for Computing Machinery
states that professional competence
begins with technical knowledge but
includes identifying in navigating
ethical challenges and the American
Society of Society of Civil Engineers
employers that we seek to be of
constructive service to our communities
for the Advancement of the safety health
and well-being those are direct
instructions and so the Charlie problem
is just the tip of the iceberg and
now have an opportunity to think more
deeply about our work and how it will
impact us in this way we can make a
neighborhood around Navis that's better
for everyone
thank you thanks so much to to allanté
for that so I feel very much like Mister
Rogers going to get a stool to come out
to the center of the stage and just talk
with you all for a little while
no so one of the things that is a real
issue that's been coming up over and
over is the importance of thinking not
just at Carnegie Mellon not just even
locally within our cities such as the
city of Pittsburgh or Arizona or Phoenix
Arizona not even just thinking
nationally but thinking internationally
when it comes to AI one of the real
challenges and opportunities of AI
technologies as has come up in a few of
the panels is this ability to simply
port these technologies for many
purposes across national boundaries and
so international and multilateral
deliberations and discussions are really
a key part of a lot of the policy and
governance efforts that are taking place
around AI and robotic and other
computational technologies in fact this
very week there are a number of
high-level discussions and deliberations
at the UN United Nations in Geneva
around the issue of the increasing
weaponization or potential for
weaponization of autonomous technologies
and so we are in fact very happy today
that two of the people who are leading
those discussions helping to shape and
guide much of our deliberation on the
international stage are gonna be joining
us by videoconference from Geneva where
they've just actually finished up a a
I'm sure very busy day and yet we're
willing to take some other time to join
us by videoconference so ambassador
Amandeep Gil currently serves as the in
at the Indian mission to the conference
on Disarmament in Geneva and has served
at the Indian Embassy in Tehran the High
Commission on
of India in Colombo and the Indian
mission to the UN in Geneva he was the
head of disarmament and international
security in the Indian Ministry of
External Affairs from 2013 until just
recently and has also served as an
expert on the UN security generals
panels of experts on the fissile
material cutoff treaty on small arms and
light weapons and on missiles he's not
simply a career diplomat though he was
actually originally educated as an
engineer at Punjab University and has a
PhD from the department of war studies
at King's College London so ambassador
Gill is one of these people that really
is merging together in this case the
policy and the technology sides together
into a single sensible perspective and
since 2017 anja cos person has served as
director for un disarmament Affairs
she's the former head of strategic
engagement in new technologies at the
International Committee of the Red Cross
the ICRC and was previously a member of
the executive committee and senior
director at the World Economic Forum
she's had a remarkable career that's
highly interdisciplinary
spanning over technology policy business
and even academia in including working
for the Norwegian government as well as
a number of international organizations
so I'm hoping that I'm going to look
over at our technical people and say I'm
hoping and we're getting I'm getting a
signal for just one more minute so one
of the things that that is a real
challenge of course even a technological
school such as this one is this
difficulty of communicating across
physical space across cultural space and
I think we've even seen some of that in
the discussions that have had been
happening certainly some of the
discussions that I've been involved with
here how do we bridge disciplinary gaps
as well there's been the talk of how do
we increase the technical literacy of
the populace at the same time I think
there have been questions about how do
we increase the understanding of the
role of ethics and values perhaps within
the technological community and I'm now
getting a thumbs-up so I'd like to say
Amandeep and Anja thank you so much for
joining us
from afar it's a great thank you for the
kind words I'm very happy to join this
discussion thank you so much so I
thought I would just start with a very
somewhat high-level and general question
for the both of you which is in terms of
thinking about international policy and
governance I'm curious what kinds of
distinctive challenges that is ones that
are new to these kinds of technologies
do you think are presented by AI and
other autonomous systems whether in the
weapons space or elsewhere right I think
in the multilateral space the biggest
challenge is to harmonize the very
different perspectives on technology in
this particular context the meeting that
I'm sharing you have 125 states with
very different economic systems with
very different levels of development
including technology development so how
do you bring everyone on to the same
page the other challenge is how do you
bring the world of technology into the
world of diplomacy and international
relations there are expert communities
in this field of which do not
necessarily interact with the technology
world it is easier in some places for
example Vienna where the International
Atomic Energy agency's that culture of
interactivity where the tech world has
been built up over the years but it's
not always so in Tudor so easy in other
places so that is the the other
challenge and third a challenge I would
say is simply keeping up with the pace
of Technology
technology moves very fast it also moves
in mysterious ways and often we are
looking at technology from the
perspective of legally binding
convention a forum with certain rules
and regulations and that's a rigid times
best
framework from which to look at
technology that's a fast-moving mutating
target so those are some of the
challenges I can think of honor thank
you thank you so much for for inviting
us as letting us be part of this
remotely just to follow up what would a
MIDI be saying the you know it's hard
enough to follow the pace of Technology
but also building the literacy on
somewhat unusual areas you know for for
the crowd that usually comes together to
discuss this this issue issues and also
to make the I will say the organic
relationships between the different
communities and the different
stakeholders to make sure that voices of
technique you know technologists and
scientists you know people in industry
in various participating in various
levels of the value chain of Technology
development but also application and
deployment you know from our civilian
life and day to day life to the armed
space so creating those organic links
and platforms to have discussions where
we can share information and and build
that much needed literacy but also
common vernacular a common use and
understanding of the terms and and some
of the developments is it's challenging
but worthwhile and something that we are
certainly working every day to try to to
remedy and and to improve there was a
mention of of the IAEA in Vienna as a
place where the technological
communities have come together at the
diplomatic are there lessons that we can
learn from the experiences around that
space that might be might be useful over
in the AI and robotics face because I
think one of the challenges is exactly
people learning to talk to one another
as you were both saying and so are there
perhaps lessons learned that we should
in this space be trying to bring to bear
well I think in jumping to the AI and
robotics space I would be careful and
Link
into existing models of governance
howsoever successful they have been this
is a unique area in many ways and unlike
the nuclear field where you know the
pathways to a nuclear weapon these are
the ways you produce fissile material
and these are the ways to count them or
to deliver them you know this is this is
a different beast and so we have to cast
a net wide to look for good examples of
governance and what I have been focusing
on is is something called the
distributed technology governance
approach where you do what you can do at
the international level at the treaty
making level but you also do that
mindful of what's happening in the
national space so in harmony in sync
with national governance national
regulation and also in sync with this
third very important level of industry
industry driven governance so these
three levels have to work in sync and
have to come together perhaps from the
nuclear space or one relatively
successful example is the Nuclear
Security Summit which President Obama
initiated where different communities
came together and they was shared
learning as soon as you brought the
issue out of the the basements of
departments of Energy Department's of
state and you injected new communities
into the discussion whether it was the
intelligence community or the scientific
community the vernacular as Anna was
saying evolved common understandings got
established and you had links to the
leaders and that speeded up the pace of
learning so AI and robotics
there are currently I would say
experiments being carried out in
governance the meeting that I'm sharing
is one such experiment these summits
that the international telecommunication
union has started since last year the AI
for good
some another experiment what i tripoli
and other industry associations are
doing with the common glossary of terms
inviting inputs from across the globe
that's another attempt at governance so
we have to be open to all these
different experiences and be creative
and be sensitive about the requirements
of these new technologies I mean thank
you it's a great question I mean in the
debate it's a lot of talk about you know
adaptive governance or distributed
governance as Amandeep was referring to
I think the the issue which we certainly
face a lot working for the UN because we
we operate on so many different levels
you know from dialogues that we are
having this week you know on the broader
strategic level to also being an
operational actor and dealing with
people in the day-to-day lives you know
being in a conflict zone or or in an
area of great development or even in a
in a more kind of modern you know
Western setting but where there are
other issues in terms of labor laws or
other regulations that need to be put in
place and what you learn seeing the sort
of scale of for me is not just the the
scale of technology development but it's
also the scale of our adoption and with
our maturity not following the same
maturity around what the impact is you
know of this adoption doesn't follow the
same pace so we have to the governance
also need to be directed towards the
different impact this will have at the
different governance levels the way you
speak about the global level the
regional level the national level the
local level more city structures and
community structures how it impacts on
industry which kind of reflects
depending on what industry you in and
the size of your industry will kind of
be linked into each one of these levels
so and that's one big challenge the
other challenge that the challenge you
know to a if you may like a unified vers
unified understanding of what governance
can mean in this space is also as I was
referring to earlier there's no there is
there's a convergent technologies are
converging at an increasing rate but are
our framing of it our understanding of
it even what we call it sometimes how we
look at that impact is not converging in
in the same way and and that's a
challenge because you find that even
within a country that whether it's the
Justice Department of the foreign
ministry department or or the Defense
Department or the people dealing with
telecommunications issues they see these
things extremely different from their
own silo so governance and you know
proper adaptive forward-looking
governance need to have greater elements
of D siloing and and converging of the
various areas and and that will take
some work but I'm very positive that we
will get there in the end yes that
certainly raises a number of questions
as you said Amandeep there's I think you
said 125 groups involved in the the
meeting that you're chairing it's hard
to imagine it that's at the
international level now start
multiplying with all of the the local
governance one can quickly see where
this is going to be a very hard problem
over many years I like to follow up on
something that had cut that I think was
latent in some of the things that both
of you were saying which is whether in
the weapons space or in other spaces
policy often requires some kind of
verification some or you know some way
of establishing a trust that that the
group that is being governed is is
following the rules as it were to put it
in very blunt terms how is that changed
for AI technologies whether again in the
weapons space or otherwise when they are
computational they aren't necessarily a
physical thing that you can pick up that
that leads it seems it seems it would
lead to a number of challenges in this
area of sort of verification and
monitoring this is an excellent question
I think the area raises some unique
questions about verification monitoring
even exchange of national good practices
no one is going to be allowing
international inspectors to pour over
their shoulders and low
get what they are coding no one is at
this point looking at turning over pages
of code because you know most of this is
happening in the commercial space so
there are proprietary intellectual
property related issues there are
commercial issues so we're not even
talking about that just in terms of what
is being developed and fielded what kind
of characteristics it has whether it
interfaces properly with existing
obligations on international
humanitarian law that itself is going to
be a huge challenge so let's leave aside
the harder problem of verifying actual
systems in terms of the coding or in
terms of their potential to learn on the
fly to be true machine learning or other
techniques so let's leave that aside the
simpler problem relatively simpler
problem of exchange of national students
that's going to be hard what I have
tried since last year is to create a
safe space for delegations to come and
talk about these systems and using a
variety of ways looking at the
technology dimension looking at the
legal ethical dimension the military
affects dimension and some cross-cutting
dimensions where this issue of being
intelligible to other communities also
comes up what kind of language we are
using how we are communicating amongst
diplomats military personnel lawyers
security experts ethicists and what
assists so to these different lenses
we've tried to get more clarity on these
issues encourage countries to talk about
them their concerns their challenges and
we hope eventually to have two things
one a system whereby the technology and
its development in space is kept under
some kind of review because whatever
governance system you come up with that
could get quickly outdated
so you need to be keep watching what's
happening in the real world and to
alongside this latter house tour you
need to have a platform for nations to
bring their experience of implementing a
use-cases regulating AI of tackling some
of the concerns whether these are social
concerns privacy related or otherwise or
these are control issues encouraging
them to bring those to the table in
exchange with others so those are
preliminary steps that we are looking at
but initially as AI develops and as it
gets applied in the security space which
seems likely to do my math then we'll
have to move up the ladder to the next
step
where we should be in a position to ask
some questions and get some answers but
we are not there now I think you know
with verification means different things
depending on the context and you ask in
terms of weapon systems and I think it's
important that what we are dealing with
here in this various for us in in UN
Geneva in particular are fundamentally
aligning or trying to reach a common
understanding of each other's national
security positions and technological and
scientific advances always been a very
key component of any national security
strategy and thinking and and and policy
and in bringing these various agendas
together I mean the two key component
for any effective verification regime is
transparency and and Trust and so how do
you build that level of transparency
without you know giving up certain I
mean doesn't have to even to be the
military or defense side of it but also
as a semantics was referring to you more
the industrial economic competitiveness
angle to it as these are truly multi
purposed technologies that would have
impact I go way beyond just II that sort
of the mers national security space so
bringing you know building that
transparency and that trust this is in
the current geopolitical climate is of
course quite challenging and it
challenges also any future verification
regime or even even to talk about
verification now in sort of the milder
form which in
world will be more referred to as
validation of that the intention and
design of the technology actually means
this it's it's targeted objectives and
just one more thing is that one thing
that we are facing and you were here the
secretary-general of the UN speak about
this is lawed is that these developments
because of the scale and the speed and
like I said the the adoption rate itself
is challenging the systems as they are
certainly challenging the entire
disarmament arms control and
non-proliferation architecture and you
know my kind of my managers and then the
sector generally in particular
constantly refers to in saying we need
normative entrepreneurship we need to
stay true to our norms our values
especially from a UN context you know
the Charter that we were built on but we
also need to be normative and thinking
you know be entrepreneurial and really
go outside our comfort zone in terms of
going back to my earlier comment you
know who do we bring in who do we talk
to how do we improve our understanding
of each other's particular circumstances
I worked a lot with the tech community
and engineering community on thinking
through this issues and one thing I
constantly see is you know diplomats and
I'm a former diplomat and diplomats or
you know civil service bureaucrats are
not always very good as thinking about
the the design the research development
the sine side of things but I would also
say that the people in the developing
research development the design phase
are not always attuned enough to the
implications of their design and so
improving that interaction so that we
can actually truly start assigning
technology in such a way that those
risks are managed upfront will require
both some normative entrepreneurship but
also entrepreneurship in general and I
would call it social or social
entrepreneurship I hope that answered
your I partially answered your question
well as you both made very clear these
are incredibly complex issues I think
you know this the talk of
entrepreneurship the talk of companies
does of course raise an issue which
which Amandeep you raised obliquely
which is so much of what's happening now
in the development in the
and AI space is happening in the
corporate world and you have these
companies that don't are no longer
restricted to national boundaries but of
course extend far beyond that so how do
we think about the engagement between
the diplomatic world and the commercial
world when you have companies whose
economic impact and economic power
exceeds that of many small nations how
can we work together between both the
political side and the economic side in
this AI and technology space it's true
and well many companies in tech space
exceeds that of many countries but at
the same time these tech companies are
very vulnerable to shifts in the public
mode to shifts in levels of trust in
them so I think it's in everyone's
interest to think about these problems
what AI and other autonomous
technologies mean for our future and
then work together to ensure that the
public continues to have trust in the
deployment of these technologies now
apart from this role I've been involved
with the national level Task Force on
deploying AI for India's economic
transformation and one of the key
enablers that we have come up with is
this issue of public confidence in AI
use cases so we have come out with some
suggestions on how to build up trust and
I think in the multilateral domain as
well I think companies would find it
useful to connect with these
conversations so if a community of arms
controllers international security
experts humanitarian law experts is
concerned about possible loss of human
control and supervision over critical
functions of n systems in the future I
think companies would be well advised to
follow that discussion try and engage
and try and influence it make sure that
we don't end up with a we
regulation scheme that offends their
plans or they don't end up with some
real use cases that upend our current
understanding of international law so I
think we need to work together as I
mentioned there are these experiments
that are taking place and I'm very happy
that we see more and more entrepreneurs
ai entrepreneurs academics young
students at these meetings they are
absorbing this policy discussion and we
are absorbing their impulses we limit we
have expert panels we try and bring
people from around the globe different
perspectives on technology and
development because the future of AI is
going to be a global future the manpower
that powers the research and development
is globe even today so I think we'll
have to think together about global
governance and work on it at different
levels in different communities in
different forums just just to add to
what Amanda said you know in in the UN
context you know we have I mean one of
the groups that has always also been
here this week its investors site which
is incredibly important you know both
for any developments happening in the
government or or in the private sphere
the UN has its framework called
sustainable development goals which is
17 goals with a bunch of loosely you
know some would say there are quite
generic but nevertheless quite detailed
indicators now these sustainable
developments small development goals
that has been adopted by all the members
of the UN so under 94 members and also
at a I think many quite surprising pick
up multinationals and industries because
they find them quite easy to work with
you know they're tough they have clear
indicators and you can measure you know
what you're doing in sort of your normal
communal operational Genuity plans
business continuity plans you know
against these these indicators and 1/2
of these goals are are actually so it's
go
number nine which is industrial gross
evasion and then goal number sixteen is
peace peace justice and strong
institutions and then you can both
seventeen which is around partnership
now if we look at this tree together you
really come out thinking okay how do we
ensure that at industrial growth and
innovation is done in a responsible way
and that we have the institutions and
the governance frameworks in place to
you know provide the right impetus and
not necessarily regulations but the
Rhind impetus and framing for for that
growth to truly benefit everyone else so
the SDGs as they called the acronym for
it you know it's not I mean it's not an
Alec heart it's not like you go with one
goal or the other but it's how do you
see how these goals converge you also
have life on land you have education
quality education and learning for all
you have children's rights and you have
gender and you know there's been a lot
of talk about you know the gender biases
and technology and technology is not
neutral and the lack of women in STEM
fields over all and so one of the other
issues looking at is nine and and gender
how do we make sure that industrial
growth and innovation also reflects the
fact that we are 50/50 share planet how
does grows an innovation reflect that we
have to really think about the future
digital footprints of our children do we
have the right framing in place which
goes to 60 again you know do you have
the right institutions in place so there
are a lot of I will call this
integrative models that would help us
move forward on this but only if we
really pay attention to it which is of
course where we all have to do our part
to make sure that happens well I'm and
depend on yeah I want to say thank you
so much for taking time in this
incredibly busy week for you I think you
know you've really laid out an enormous
space but it's a complex one but one
that we might hope is tractable through
the kinds of diplomatic efforts that
you're leading and the kinds of
conversations that we're trying to have
here in Pittsburgh and we really
appreciate you taking this time when I'm
sure it's been a hectic day already for
you thank you very much great pleasure
thank you
so as we were just talking the it's a
space of incredible complexity it's a
spray space where the on the ground
kinds of details matter how these
policies get implemented who's able to
get in the room to have these
discussions and how do we make sure that
it's all the right issues that are
supporting the human whether it be
political or economic or technological
needs so we're gonna in the remainder of
the session have two more spotlights
followed by a conversation spotlight by
laurie faith Craner of Carnegie Mellon
and Kay Firth Butterfield but from the
World Economic Forum and to introduce
and moderate the subsequent conversation
I'm pleased to welcome back up Tom Simon
night from Wired magazine thank you so
our first speaker is Laurie crema she's
a great person to have up here being as
she is a professor of computer science
but also public policy and engineering
here at Carnegie Mellon she's been a
pioneer in researching the usability and
human aspects of security and privacy
and she spent 2016 as the chief
technologist at the Federal Trade
Commission Lori please join us thank you
I'm really delighted to be here today so
increasingly algorithms are being used
to make decisions that impact our lives
as we've heard about earlier today the
privacy concerns we have about the
collection of our social network data
transactions location traces and other
information are made all the worse by
the uncertainty about how our
information is going to be used and
analyzed by algorithms that we don't
understand and may not even know exists
much of my labs research focuses on
privacy when we interview people about
online privacy
they are often puzzled about why ads for
online merchants that they visited
yesterday
are following them around the internet
today they don't understand where their
data goes or how it is used by
algorithms to target ads to them besides
being used to target ads algorithms may
be used for decisions that may have a
big impact on our lives for example to
decide whether we qualify for a mortgage
or other loan they may also be used to
decide whether we're interviewed for a
job or have the opportunity to enroll in
college or as we recently learned
algorithms are used to decide what
political ads to show us on social media
thus algorithms may be used not only to
market to us but to manipulate us and
potentially to impact our political
process algorithms make decisions about
us all the time and as we are hearing
throughout this conference algorithms
often encode bias where does this bias
come from machine learning algorithms
are trained with a set of training data
that teaches the algorithm through
examples of matching and non matching
patterns the choice of training data set
can impact the decisions the algorithm
makes indeed any biases inherent in the
training set whether introduced
intentionally or unintentionally will
likely show up in the algorithms
decisions for example a hiring algorithm
trained with data from past hires will
likely reproduce past prejudice and
continue to hire people with the same
characteristics thus it may be biased
towards hiring people of a particular
gender or people of a particular race or
people who attended certain schools
as awareness of algorithmic
decision-making increases with it comes
calls for algorithmic transparency what
is algorithmic transparency this is the
idea that we should be able to provide
explanations about how an algorithm
makes decisions we want to know when
algorithms are making decisions and how
those decisions are being made but this
can be difficult to determine and even
more difficult to explain when the
algorithms are based on simple rules it
may be relatively straightforward for
example here it is easy to tell someone
why they are seeing an ad for sweaters
and dresses there's a little blue
triangle icon I can click on that gives
me more information as you can see it
seems that these were the last products
that I viewed on this website and people
who looked at these products often ended
up choosing the ones that they are
advertising to me but when decisions are
based on artificial intelligence it may
be difficult to determine exactly why a
particular decision was made and the
explanations may not all be all that
insightful here is an example from my
own research a couple of years ago we
developed a password meter that analyzed
the password as a user created it and
used neural networks to come up with a
guess ability score the guess ability
score indicates the number of guesses
that the algorithm predicts it will take
an attacker to guess that password so
the higher the guess ability score the
stronger the password and that's good
the problem is that if the algorithm
just tells you your password is rated
575 or even your password is weak create
a strong password you still don't have
any information that will help you make
the password better my students came up
with a clever way to solve this problem
they generated
list of 21 heuristics for things users
do that make their passwords bad for
example they may include dictionary
words they may include common phrases
like I love you they may capitalize
letters only at the beginning or mean or
they may put all their digits at the end
which is a very common thing people use
to create passwords they make make
passwords that aren't long enough or
they might not use any symbols my
students analyzed 30,000 stolen
passwords using the neural network and
determined statistically how much each
of these 21 heuristics accounted for the
guess ability of each password this
allowed them to weight the heuristics to
determine which ones mattered the most
then after analyzing a password using
both the neural network and the
heuristics the password meter could
determine the top three reasons a
password was likely rated as bad by the
neural network and present those in
plain English to the users this approach
does not tell us precisely why the
neural network made the decision it did
and if the neural network figures out
something that is not captured by the
heuristics we won't be able to recognize
it let alone explain it to the user
but our user studies demonstrated that
overall this approach gives us
meaningful information that aids user
understanding and helps people improve
their passwords now this approach won't
work to explain all algorithmic
decision-making but it is an approach of
one - it is what an example of one type
of an approach towards achieving
algorithmic transparency but this is
just one approach and it's a fairly
simple one more research is needed to
come up with other approaches that will
help us provide algorithm algorithmic
transparency without resorting to
spitting out internal algorithmic
details that make sense only to experts
or maybe to no one at all there are many
researchers hard at work on this
including some of my colleagues here at
Carnegie Mellon but we have a ways to go
and indeed we may not ever be able to
fully explain how AI algorithms work in
a way that makes sense
to non experts in 2017 the Association
for Computing Machinery released seven
principles for algorithmic transparency
and accountability I will paraphrase
them here briefly the first principle is
awareness be aware of potential biases
and their potential harm there is a
temptation to assume that the algorithm
is pure and unbiased and can't be wrong
people blindly report that they're just
doing what the computer told them to do
the awareness principle encourages us to
think through sources of potential bias
and ways that people may be harmed by
algorithms and make sure that all
stakeholders are aware of this access
and redress adopt mechanisms for
questioning and redress by those who may
be adversely affected it is important
that we not delegate decisions to
algorithms without any ability to ask
questions or appeal their decisions if
someone wants to challenge a decision
there should be a clear process through
which they can request information about
how a decision was made and challenge it
it is not enough to know how a decision
was made but we need a mechanism to
investigate and correct faulty
decision-making accountability
organizations should be held accountable
for decisions made by algorithms they
use even if they can't explain how the
algorithm produced those results it is
important than a non-transparent
algorithm not be used as an excuse for
decisions and a way to dodge
accountability it is not acceptable for
an organization to throw up their hands
and say we didn't program the algorithm
to discriminate we don't know what it
learned from the training data that
caused it to be biased it's not our
response
ability if organizations are going to
delegate their decision-making to
algorithms they must be held accountable
for the decisions those algorithms make
even if they can't explain why the
algorithms made those decisions you
can't sue an algorithm or at least not
yet I think but you should be able to
sue the organization has decided to
blindly rely on the algorithm
explanation explain how the algorithm
works and how it makes specific
decisions this is particularly important
in public policy context as I discussed
it is not always possible to explain
specific algorithmic decisions in a
meaningful way however there is usually
something that can be explained that
will provide insights into how the
algorithm works generally at the very
least we can illustrate the algorithms
functionality by example we can show a
large set of inputs and what decision
the algorithm makes in response to each
data provenance be aware of how training
data was collected and explore potential
biases induced by that process if
possible allow public scrutiny of
training data the data used to train an
algorithm can make a big difference in
how an algorithm makes decisions for
example a healthcare algorithm that is
trained using data mostly from men may
not be very good at making healthcare
decisions for women in my passwords
research we have found that a passwords
cracking algorithm trained on passwords
that are mostly 8 characters or shorter
is not very good at cracking longer
passwords this is also where biases can
get baked in in computer science we have
been struggling to recruit more women so
data sets about computer science
students or tech company employees are
likely to have few women and even fewer
racial minorities and these data sets
are used to train algorithms that will
be used to make
hiring or college admissions decissions
they may make decisions biased against
women and minorities if we allow people
to examine the data on which an
algorithm is trained they may be able to
discover biases or deficiencies in the
training data that may reduce the
quality of the decisions it makes
sometimes training data is proprietary
or contains confidential information so
it may not be possible to publish it or
expose it in its entirety but we may
still be able to provide information
about how it was collected and allow
experts to examine the full data set
auditability record models algorithms
data and decisions so they can be
audited when harm is suspected it is
important to keep a record of how an
algorithm is created trained and used so
we have the ability to trace what
happened should we suspect that it
behaved in a harmful way we may not be
able to trace exactly what happened in
an understandable way but maintaining
these records can provide important
insights finally validation and testing
routinely test models to determine
whether they generate discriminatory
harm document results and make them
public let's not just assume our
algorithms are unbiased and hope for the
best we need to test them in on a
regular basis with a diverse set of
inputs to determine the types of
decisions they make if the decisions are
discriminatory or harmful we need to
adjust the algorithms to reduce bias by
documenting and publicizing this process
we can allow for public input and
increase the overall trust in the system
so now getting back to the topic of this
session policy and governance should we
regulate algorithmic transparency can we
write this into law the seven ACM
principle seemed like a good starting
point they've been well thought out by a
group of experts considering both
technical and ethical issues but we
haven't had too much experience putting
the
to practice yet they were just published
last year it seems to me that we should
start by encouraging voluntary adoption
of these principles and in gain
experience with them
however voluntary principles may not be
sufficient in some domains going forward
there may not be sufficient incentives
for organizations to adopt them thus at
some point it may be useful to
incorporate some or all of these
principles into regulation thank you
thank you very much Laurie please please
take a seat we'll have a chance to talk
about some of those fascinating points
after our next speaker and our next
speaker is Kate Firth Butterfield she
has a background in law and has worked
as a barrister and judge in the UK but
since September of last year she has
been with the World Economic Forum where
she leads a new project on AI and
machine learning
please welcome Kate good afternoon
ladies and gentlemen it's a great honor
to be speaking at an AI and ethics
conference that's actually sponsored by
lawyers and in honor of that I'm sort of
channeling the former trial lawyer in me
by wearing all black and also dispensing
with PowerPoint actually dispensing with
PowerPoint is in the hope that you'll
listen to me rather than trying to make
sense or read my slides so I have been
asked to speak about the challenges of
good governance in AI in other words how
we think about shaping this technology
for good across multiple stakeholders
government business ideas NGOs civil
society and academia because this isn't
as simple as just trust this is more
complex because the technology itself is
very fast changing all the time and is
complex as well so we need to be much
more
jaelyn the way that we think about these
governance mechanisms and I guess that
like like me you've been thinking that
actually the future is not shaped by
technology it's shaped by us but
increasingly we're sort of in this
feeling that actually the technology is
out there and we're reacting to things
rather than actually directing them so
my purpose in this very short speech is
really to talk about a couple of things
around traditional governance mechanisms
and then to propose some what I call
additive agile forms of governance at
least and I'm going to illustrate that
by some of the things that we're
actually doing at the World Economic
Forum out in San Francisco say first of
all thinking about there's two big
things of traditional governance
legislation or regulation well with this
technology moving so fast we're very
often in what could be called the too
late zone saved by the time we've
legislated the horses not is four or
five fields down there down the road and
lane and so once we undoubtedly will
need some regulations on legislation in
this area we need to be thoughtful about
what we tackle additionally we can't
legislate what we can't define and as
both lawyers and scientists we all know
that the definitions in this space are
really difficult and so it looks as if
maybe we'll be legendary legislating a
in terms of product rather than the
artificial intelligence or machine
learning itself but that insert in
itself leaves problems and if you have
bad legislation what does that lead to
well that leads in our jurisdiction to
lawyers debating in court what was meant
by the legislation
say let's think about the scenario a
moment we have perhaps in a fairly lowly
Court two lawyers who don't really
understand the legislative the
legislation or the technology very well
trying to convince a judge to make a
decision and that judge doesn't
necessarily understand the technology
very well and then you have experts who
may or may not be good experts this is
not necessarily the way I would submit
that we want to construct our legal
system and our laws in this area moving
forwards so what are the additives that
we can bring to this traditional
government system well I would say that
leadership in this area needs to come
from two different perspectives first of
all we need to ask ourselves not only
what we govern that definitions piece
but I will say the question why and how
we're going to do this which may not be
that traditional mechanism but rather
agile governance roots and as we at the
forum would say and I will read you the
definition agile governance is adaptive
human centered inclusive sustainable
policy policy development which is not
limited to government's but rather is an
increasingly multi-stakeholder effort
it's a continued readiness to rapidly
navigate change and to learn from change
and in reactively embrace change whilst
also contributing to actual or perceived
user value so if I can adjust unpick
that for a little bit some examples of
what I'm talking about first of all the
development of and you
of standards safe standards from the I
Triple E the forums aim protocols
recently on the use of the Internet of
Things and something Laurie talked about
earlier the ACM rules the emergence of
social norms which constrain or endorse
the technology private incentive schemes
Eric talked yesterday about
certification oversight by professional
bodies industria greement sand policies
which organizations apply voluntarily
for example like ether also something
Eric talked about yes Jake or by
contract within their relationships with
competitors suppliers partners and
customers also we should think about
whether there is actually existing law
that deals with some of these things so
for example company law in Europe
requires companies not just to look at
the their profit and loss sheets but it
will say at the impact their company is
having on stake holders why in the wider
world also Germany recently used an old
telecommunications act to ban AI toys
because of the concerns are around
hacking and values-based legislation
that's already on the books we know what
Europe thinks for good or ill about
privacy because it passed the GD P R and
therefore it said privacy is so
important that we want it designed in at
the start so agile governance it
includes not only the traditional
lawmakers international national state
and local governments and then the
courts interpreting that but also
industry civil society and academia say
picking up on all of those pieces of
agile governance what the former has
done
create what we call a do tank to work in
this multi-stakeholder environment on
the governance not only of AI but also
blockchain IOT autonomous vehicles
drones precision medicine ecommerce and
cross-border data phase and what we call
in for IR technologies around the
environment we work on projects each one
is 18 months long and we have a
commitment from the partners that were
working with to actually pilot these
projects in the last six months of that
18-month period and all projects have to
have our cross-cutting themes of ethics
and values social inclusion and putting
the human in the middle of this thinking
as we designed for the benefit of
humanity as a whole say this multi
stakeholder group also includes fellows
working on our projects from all of
these different multi-stakeholders i've
spoken about and so we're actually
delighted that CMU will be sending us
fellows to work on these projects with
us and so we're really looking forward
to welcoming them in San Francisco and I
think so that you can really understand
the background of what I'm talking about
in terms of agile governments I just
want to give you four exemplars from the
projects that we are actually doing in
San Francisco so the first one is a
number of speakers have said well we
need to stop interesting science
projects without thinking about what the
future looks like and those of you who
read The Guardian article an interview
with Christopher Wiley will have noted
that it said he thrilled to the
intellectual possibilities of it he
didn't think of the consequences
and so with Ella and Jennifer Keating we
have a project co-creating a way of
helping to increase the number of a ice
young AI scientists so undergraduates
graduates and post graduates to really
think through these consequences and the
way the project works is very simple
people like Ella who have already
thought through these things and created
curricula will deposit their curricula
into a repository on the World Economic
Forum's website and we will ask
professors from around the world who are
yet to teach this to you take vote that
curricula
use it customize it put their own
cultural values into it and then all
that we ask is that you put it back into
the repository for other people to use
so you might say well how is that
governance well actually you know if we
can influence ethical curricula in
universities all around the world then
there'll be many young a AI scientists
globally who understand the importance
of ethical thinking a second one is
obviously as robotics and AI systems
become more powerful and more capable
than the decision making process for
boards and managers of companies really
rise in importance thinking about AI so
we're with our partners creating a board
toolkit that will help them to ask the
right questions it'll help them to think
about the ethics of AI that they're
deploying in their company how they're
deploying it how they're thinking about
their work force creating best practices
around deployment and perhaps even
creating something like Microsoft has or
an ethics advisory board of some sort so
again how does that fit into the agile
governance
well it's agile governments through
informed boards or as I said companies
voluntarily applying governance methods
then we have two projects which work
actually with governments
so the first will be working with
government partners to cope to co-create
soft regulation drawing a line in the
sand
the project will co-create best
practices for those governments and then
those governments will say if we are
going to buy artificial intelligence the
artificial intelligence product that we
buy for our government and use in our
government must first meet these best
practices I'm sure that it's very simple
for you to see that what that does is
it's agile governance it's the
government government instead of passing
law saying well you need to meet these
criteria and this is what is acceptable
to us regarding AI within our
jurisdiction and then I want you to just
with me imagine what a regulator of the
future might look like so again working
with countries to imagine perhaps Eric
certifying body as you know the current
regulator waits for something to go
wrong and then moves in and probably
finds people well what we want to think
about is a regulator that works with
businesses to create to help create
technology which then the regulator can
certify it can say this AI is fit for
the purpose said that government can be
say that the government can be assured
the citizens can be assured and the
company can know that it's put its tech
dollar it's its R&D dollars into doing
something that it can think
now because this is a global issue we
won't just be having projects based here
in San Francisco but in we will also be
having sister centers around the world
doing projects that that are applicable
globally so at the moment
starting in India China and Japan and
obviously wanting to move into the
developing world because I'm sure like
you like me don't want to see the
developing world falling any further
behind as a result of these technologies
so each project that we do is actually
an agile governance model which although
we've done with one or two countries
over here will be available to the rest
of the world to actually use as a model
so you might say to me who governs the
governance and and I have an answer for
that we will be creating a global AI
Council or we are in the process of
creating the global AI Council which
will be empowered to look across the
world think about AI and make
recommendations for those projects that
we should be thinking about doing
they're comprised of world leaders from
government say for example Prime
Minister Mei has agreed to serve
business civil society international
global organizations and academia so
this has been a really concrete talk but
I hope it's been helpful to actually
sort of get down to some of the bones of
these ideas and think deeply about the
complex nature of what good governance
looks like in this area and I hope that
we can continue that conversation on our
panel thank you
thank you very much Kay and thank you
for joining us for the panel as well so
you you both alluded to the fact that
there are many different forms of
governance and some of them involve
governments so maybe we could start with
that I think it's interesting that both
of you have experience trying to engage
governments on complex technical
subjects that are at the you know
leading edge of technological
development and I wondered if you could
reflect a little bit on what what that
is like you know how the governments
come at subjects like AI or privacy
perhaps in a way that's different from
technologists and are they equipped to
deal with these things how do you help
that process so Laurie maybe you could
start
so I spent 2016 as chief technologists
at the Federal Trade Commission and it
was in some ways kind of a surreal
experience because this was an agency of
a thousand people and I was one of two
PhD technologists in the agency most of
that time and there were a handful of
other technical people there were a lot
of lawyers and I think about a hundred
economists so the thing is that the
Federal Trade Commission is actually an
agency that deals a lot with technology
a lot of a lot of what they regulate and
a lot of the issues increasingly are
based on technology and I think there
are a lot of attorneys and economists
there who are pretty proficient and
talking about technology but they are
also aware that they need more expertise
so I obviously couldn't provide all of
the expertise that was needed I didn't
have the time nor you know my expertise
is relatively narrow so I spent a lot of
time helping them reach out to experts
who might be able to bring in the
expertise that they needed and also
encouraging them to hire more
technologists but but I think this is
not an atypical experience in US
government agents
you know they're starting to bring in
technologists but they don't necessarily
have enough for the kind of policymaking
that they're increasingly getting called
on to do right okay what's your
experience there's some governments it
sounds like are actively engaging with
this topic do they come at it in a
different way from other people in the
room or that we've heard on stage talk
about it I I I think that what we're
finding at the Forum is that actually
governments are really a number of
governments are really interested in
this topic and are doubtful as to what
they should be doing and what
governments mechanisms are necessary and
so we have partners at the Forum a
number of governments who are actually
working with us in San Francisco and
give you an idea of diversity Japan to
Rwanda so lots of governments interested
and wanting to to do better okay and are
there some emerging models of how
different governments are doing that I
mean one idea I've heard discussed here
in the u.s. is maybe the government
should have a federal agency for AI or
robotics and then I like its way to
having a federal Food and Drug
Administration I mean is anyone
exploring that possibility yes I think
the obviously there's going to be a
Center for data ethics in the UK which
was budgeted for in November and there
is a segment of one of the ministries
that has now become an AI and AI sickest
piece of that ministry obviously you've
got the Minister of Juba a minister of
AI
the UAE what is his remit what does a
Minister for very I do you probably
better ask him bad but my understanding
is to think about all the possible ways
in which AI would be used within the
country and that really gels with some
of some other countries that are
producing AI strategies say like we we
famously know of the China AI strategies
so lots and and president macron spoke
recently about the way that France would
be so I think there is lots of interest
in developing strategies and people
thinking about a specific okay you must
have mentioned president macrons plan
and I think that was interesting because
he well it's a little bit unusual to
have a world leader say you know now is
the time to be thinking about rules for
AI but he also went a bit further and
said these rules are going to impose
certain cultural characteristics that we
value in France on to the technology and
he sort of painted this picture of you
know a certain Frenchness about the
systems that will be created under this
this framework is that a model you think
other countries might adopt I don't know
whether its model that other countries
might adopt but it's certainly something
that I think that those of us working in
AI and ethics come up with a lot you
know whose ethics anyway
and so I about the project that illa and
Jennifer and the iron co-creating and
really sort of helping people to think
about their own cultural frames of
reference for using their technology and
if we think about use of AI globally and
perhaps extrapolator and bring in the
developing world they're going to have
very different needs
for AI technology than we have and so it
would it be understandable that they
would want to have their own cultural
reference I see okay and right at the
end of your talk you mentioned the I
think it was the Global Council what
will function will that serve I mean do
you imagine it helping with the issue
you just mentioned there of ensuring
that all countries get some benefits I
mean will it set international norms
about the technology what is the goal
the idea isn't to set international
norms the idea is to help us to think
about which projects we should be
working on across the various centers of
which will be located around the world
and so aspects of the projects that I've
already discussed today okay Laurie you
spoke about these ACM principles and you
spoke a little bit at the end there
about the path forward for those so
maybe you could expand on that are
people you know signing allegiance to
that document yeah is it does it operate
just that the level of organizations or
individuals how is how is this going to
work so so as far as I know people
aren't specifically signing allegiance
to it I think it was put out there as I
guess kind of an aspirational document
okay okay and I wonder if your
experience in privacy could help us look
ahead a little bit as to what might
happen with a iron governance so one
pattern in technology policy and I think
privacy is that people like when
informed people like yourself will do
some research and put your hands up and
said that there could be a problem with
this we need to be thinking about this
issue and nothing much happens until
there's a terrible incident and then you
know maybe the courts are involved at
all there's certainly interest from
policy makers I could see that happening
in AI as well I don't know if you agree
I mean is there an example from privacy
that might help us think about those
types of scenarios
yeah I think we've seen that repeatedly
in privacy so in the United States we
don't actually have much in the way of
privacy laws and back in the 1980s we we
didn't even really have health care data
privacy laws and there was somebody a
judge who was being considered for the
supreme court judge Bork and in the in
that process there was a lot of people
who are trying to dig up dirt on him and
a journalist went to the video rental
store that he rented videos from and was
able to get all his video rental records
and and then this was published in the
major newspapers and you know there
wasn't really much in it other than he
had bad taste in movies but you know the
expectation had been that there would be
you know some adult entertainment or
whatnot and immediately we saw members
of Congress falling over themselves to
try to outlaw this and try to make it so
that you could not go to a video rental
store and get somebody's records and
they very quickly passed the video
rental Privacy Protection Act in record
time and our video rental records to
this day are among the best protected
personal data records in the United
States okay
that's a I mean can we think of a
possible scenario in in the case of the
application of AI where there's a risk
of a sudden incident that causes big
change yeah well I think in AI the most
likely scenario is that somebody dies
and and I think we're already starting
to see that with self-driving cars where
there's been some unfortunate accidents
recently that I think are causing people
to ask questions and they say you know
how can we let these car companies do
this do we need to regulate them do we
need to stop them maybe they're moving
too fast
I see
and okay you you spoke about a concern
you have that there may be you know
cases that end up before a court that's
not particularly well prepared you do
you see a particular way to prepare for
that materiality or stop it is that one
of the goal or preventive I suppose it's
not currently a project that we're
running at the forum but it is something
that I worked with on one of the Supreme
Court justices in the United Kingdom to
begin to educate lawyers and judges and
the Royal Society actually has a
training group that teaches judges about
technical issues and so I think there is
some level of preparation that I know of
in the UK but I don't have anything and
the forum is working with governments
but there are also companies involved is
that is that right what what is driving
companies to come come forward is is it
you know sometimes people talk about a
classic race to hear to self-regulate
before you know state regulation comes
into play is that that driver or is it
people adding concern about these topics
to the corporate responsibility you know
manifesto well the companies come from
very diverse countries there we have
companies from countries around the
world from South America from Africa
from China from Japan Europe America and
I will actually have 15 different
businesses working on my projects and
they are coming because the AI is
something that and emerging technologies
governments of emerging technologies is
something that they are now thinking
very deeply about and as I say if you're
thinking if you think of companies in
Japan for example they're thinking about
how they can ramp up to address okay and
one of the governance mechanisms that's
forming is it is a kind of
self-regulation and the partnership on
AI I has been discussed on this stage we
have tried that before on technical
topics haven't we I wonder if you know
it might reflect a little bit on on that
you know there has been a degree of
self-regulation around privacy in the US
for example yes as I said we don't have
a lot of privacy laws in the u.s. and we
have relied very heavily on
self-regulation in the privacy space and
I've been involved in it since the late
1990s it's been rather frustrating that
we have industry and advocates come
together and come up with privacy self
regulatory programs and then the
incentives don't actually exist for them
to become widely adopted and we keep
seeing this cycle of people saying we
have a problem let's come up with a
solution we come up with a solution we
issue a press release we celebrate and
nobody does anything and then a few
years later we do it all again so I
think there's great flexibility in
self-regulation and I think it's a
really good idea to be able to instead
of having people in Congress who don't
necessarily know a lot about the
technology decide let the experts come
together and develop self regulatory
programs but at the same time I think we
need some incentives so that they'll
actually be adopted okay
miss president our alternative model is
presented by gdpr which in the European
Union sets down some very broad rules
and it also kind of applies to AI or
some application machining as well
doesn't it yeah yeah so the European
privacy laws are very broad and they
have lots of very detailed provisions
it's not entirely clear what they mean
yet we'll find out when they start
enforcing it but I think there there are
parts of it that are very well
intentioned and I agree with their goal
to protect privacy but I disagree with
some of the mechanisms that are written
into the law that I think practically
don't make a lot of sense for really
protecting privacy and so I think that
that's a concern okay okay presumably
you're quite familiar with gdpr and so
far as anyone can be here this I wonder
are there things in there that might be
useful inspiration to people who are
thinking about governance of AI well as
I said I think one of the things that is
interesting about the G GPR is is that
it does show the values the value set
and say you're looking at sort of value
alignment governance there I am NOT an
expert on GDP that's actually somebody
who's head of cross-border data players
at the at the Forum but it's it's games
I think it's interesting because as
companies around the world gear up to
deal with it they're making to perhaps
find that they're incorporating that in
their own self regulatory mechanisms so
I think it's interesting from that
perspective and I think there's been a
question actually as to whether gdpr
requires things like algorithmic
transparency and I've seen debates about
that and I'm not enough of an expert in
gdpr to really weigh it's probably good
for the audience there were know about
to get into that but the point you made
then about transparency and also in your
your talk and I think you touched on it
okay is that some of the things we have
done in the past where governance will
apply in this area but it seems like
there are some characteristics of
machine learning and AI based
technologies that are very different and
they're challenging and so you mentioned
Laurie that you know you want to ask
people to be transparent about how
things work but you also had a carve out
saying you know we accept that sometimes
you won't know exactly or you won't be
able to exactly explain it right so
that's kind of that's the challenge
isn't it yeah I mean I think currently
we we often can't fully explain the
decisions that AI is making and they're
people who are working on trying to do
it and I think they'll get us closer
there but I I think ultimately we're not
gonna be able to explain everything as
much as we would like okay is that is
that a challenge or a problem I mean you
know people talk about the black box
problem and and suggest that there are
certain things we can't use these
systems for until we are able to explain
fully well so I think this the ACM
principle suggests there are ways of
having accountability even if you can't
fully explain everything that's going on
inside the black box and so you know the
approach of throwing a lot of inputs at
it and seeing what comes out and being
able to look statistically these kind of
inputs drive these kind of outputs may
be satisfactory
in some cases for providing enough of an
explanation as to what's going on I see
I think it's probably interesting the
structure to just go back to one of the
things I mentioned about agile
governance and that's a standard setting
and it may be useful to know that the I
Triple E is actually working on the
standard to require transparency and so
that follows up on some of the ACM
things so standard setting in this space
is something that we should be watching
okay and I think you alluded to this Kay
that there's also this question of these
systems you know you may develop and
test it and then deploy it and it may
continue to change
behavior it may be may have a very
different behavior for different people
for example over time and I guess that's
a challenge but for government
structures as well yes absolutely it's
such a it's a challenge for all
government structures so just as much as
it's a challenge for how do we define it
and legislate against it it's also a
problem for other forms of agile
governance and I it's going to be
something that we find as we move
forward say for example one of my
students when I was teaching this as a
law class came up with the idea that
perhaps one would have a robot who would
be taught to be sexist and by its
ultimate owner and then it goes ahead
and kills somebody because of that who
you know where do you where do you
create where do you put the blame or on
the safe software manufacturer the
hardware manufacturer and we weave those
things we're still grappling with ok
well I'm afraid that's we have time for
please thank Lori and Kay
and now we'll hand back over to David
thank you Tom Laurie and Kato is really
great and it was a it was wonderful to
see sort of the complexities at work
right the sorts of things that onion
Amandeep laid out is these real
challenges that we're gonna have to
wrestle with on the governance
perspective to see what it looks like as
it were on the ground all the challenges
that we have to try and struggle with so
this unfortunately we were supposed to
have one other person I did want to
mention Sola and Baracus from Cornell
University was unfortunately unable to
join us at the last minute and so we
were supposed to have another voice but
we'll have to wait until the next
conference I supposed to bring Solan so
this concludes this session on policy
and governance we have a coffee break
and a few refreshments in the back room
and we'll be starting the session on
agency and empowerment at two o'clock
thank you so much
[Music]